c'est très simple on jarry et on va
regarder ce qu'il ya dans la cabine à et
tu vas devoir dire aux téléspectateurs
ce que tu vois
ok d'accord ils vont devoir dire qu'ils
bluffent de nous deux d'accord c'est que
c'est une séquence que vous attendent à
chaque fois je vais tu veux démarrer ou
tu veux je démarre comme tu le sens bâti
mon chéri des marques et la regarde ce
que tu vois je prends le temps mon chéri
et je le dis maintenant ce que j'ai vu
ouais j'ai vu gilles alma déguisé en
astérix qui qui a un chat entre les
mains et qui est en train de maltraiter
d'accord faut pas maltraiter des animaux
non et s'il vous plaît pas qu'est ce
qu'on fait vous pomper sur quelqu'un que
vous connaissez pas voilà vous
rencontrez quelqu'un
et qu'est ce que vous faites mathieu
devant mon âge je veux pas des roses ça
c'est sûr
qu'est ce que je fais ah non mais j'y
vais directement
bah oui dites quoi j'ai envie de toi
rien ne laissait pas la personne
absolument
j'ai envie de toi ça déstabilise
d'entrée mais après ils vont fait péter
s'orienter contournement physique ça
marche assez souvent ah oui oui j'ai lu
chan en boîte de nuit je ne recommande
pas cette technique et gilles verdez
aujourd'hui il est en cours mais toi pas
ca c
moi je regarde ce que je vois et moi
bien je vous le jure il ya thierry
beccaro en train de jouer avec ses
boules alors à votre avis d eric bloch
et les boeufs
cyril bluff je suis alors je suis
sincère quand le garçon on peut se
défendre ou comment ça se passe alors
vous pensez qu un vigile cyril vous
bluffez vous ai vu dans les yeux de
jarry la sincérité
ah ouais et dans les messieurs la
fausseté géraldine maillet voulons
envoyer un bouquin oui j'écris un livre
moi benjamin amoureuse de moi à ma maman
m'a annoncé qu'on peut nier cela oui une
fois en lieu sûr vous sortez votre seul
et là il est avec nous ce soir c'est la
trame icher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous c'est de la faire rire
elles ont atteint conseil reste à une
autre femme
c'est mon frère oui vous moi je parle
pendant des heures pour la cible et ça
marche à la fin ouais mais c'est le mec
vous connaissez tous les gars comme ça
qu'ils ont les mêmes pas l'usure alliant
les meufs à la fin ils ont pas tellement
plus font pas dit c'est quoi vas-y tu es
sur moi et parfois vite après c'est vrai
ça marche bien alors je vais te tuer
vous dire je vais vous dire ce qu'il ya
derrière il y à une star internationale
qui fait de la boxe
quand je vous dis une star
internationale il y a mike tyson
derrière sur le poker
j'envoie agathe et au moment fatidique
on éteint la lumière et c'est la
surprise
moi comme toujours depuis 25 ans je fais
un chèque
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et puis c'est qu'ils charrient on a fait
toute cette séquence que pour sa part et
applaudissant sociale et la vie et merci
mon chéri versus et du cpie de l'équipe
c'est notamment grâce à dumont beghi